[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
du 7-8 débat seveso ce mot vous l'avez
sans doute entendu à de nombreuses
reprises cette année et pour cause il a
fait la une de l'actualité plusieurs
sites classés sous cette directive
européenne qui recense les risques
industriels majeurs ont été victimes
d'un incendie récemment le ciapa cher en
juillet lubrizol à rouen septembre et ce
week-end la plus grande raffinerie de
france près du havre
ces sites seveso sont ils assez protégé
contrôler comment prévenir les incidents
la population est elle suffisamment
informés c'est le débat du mois pour
parler de ce sujet trois invités autour
de la table en vie quels thèmes bachère
bonsoir bonsoir êtes le responsable de
l'unité départementale de la drieu
yvelines drieu c'est la direction
régionale et interdépartementale et de
l'environnement et de l'énergie marie
josé rossi jaouen bonsoir présidente du
fn eu 78 c france nature environnement
la fédération des associations de
défense de la nature et de
l'environnement et didier fischer
bonsoir bonsoir mr de coignières quoi
dire qui est concerné par cette
thématique seveso car deux sites classés
seveso sont implantés dans votre commune
merci à tous les trois d'avoir répondu
favorablement à notre invitation et je
précise d'ores et déjà que nous avons
sollicités et des responsables de sites
seveso en l'occurrence ceux du siaap à
achères et de total à gargenville ils
n'ont pas souhaité venir ce soir en
plateau je vous propose pour commencer
de regarder cette carte très site classé
seveso dans le département des yvelines
dont six en seuil haut on expliquera la
différence tout à l'heure avec goût
henry a calqué ma chère ses sites en
seuil haut sont dans les commune
d'achères coignières ben lima
gargenville et sentis liés la ville est
ce qu'il y à un risque industriel
particulièrement élevées sur le
département des yvelines où finalement
pas pas plus que dans les autres
départements alors pas plus que dans les
autres départements surtout la
caractéristique de ceux de ses
installations seveso
c'est ce qu'on pourrait qualifier de ses
installations seveso de la vie
quotidienne c'est à dire c'est les
installations qui répondent à des
besoins de la vie quotidienne de nos
de nos concitoyens par des sites seveso
seuil haut ce sont des stockages de gaz
ce sont ben et scintille et ce sont des
stockages d'hydrocarbures pour
l'alimentation nos véhicules et puis
deux installations qui traite plus
particulièrement nos déchets c'est le
siaap donc vous venez d évoquer mais ces
eaux est également la sarp ali mais qui
fait de l'incinération de déchets par
exemple les déchets toxiques que vous
mettez aujourd'hui en déchetteries sont
incinérés dans cette installation qui la
répartition de ces sites si on doit
faire la différence à une différence à
faire entre des sites en seuil haut et
seuil bas quelle est la différence
globalement c'est la nature du risque et
surtout l'importance de ce risque pour
donner un ordre d'idée en matière de
liquides inflammables
entre 5000 tonnes et 50000 vous êtes
cédé au seuil bas au delà de 50 milles
vous êtes ainsi cédé au soleil trop
donc c'est véritablement le potentiel de
danger l'importance du stockage ou des
manipulations qui sont faites qui va
engendrer ou non ce classement cdo avec
des incidents dans l'actualité je le
disais cet incident a cher en juillet
dernier l'usiné lubrizol aussi en
septembre près à rouen lui aussi eu un
incendie dans un site seveso en
eure-et-loir et donc ce week end je
disais tout à l'heure la plus grande
raffinerie de france le site total du
havre qui donc et ses deux plus grandes
raffineries de france on voit qu'il ya
eu de nombreux incidents récemment ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que ces
sites sont sensibles et que finalement
la les potentiels accidents sont alors
par définition les ans contre les sites
qui relèvent de cette directive là sont
des sites dangereux cirque qui ont un
potentiel de danger important
bien entendu leur classement seveso fait
qu' ils sont soumis à un certain nombre
de dispositifs de contrôle et le premier
d'entre eux c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'étude de dangers c'est dire qu'on va
être en situation de recenser la
totalité des accidents potentiels et en
face de ces accidents potentiels de
proposer à la fois des mesures de
réduction du risque donc de la
probabilité que ce danger apparaissent
mais également de l'intervention de
l'intervention au niveau du site
si l'accident est maîtrisable au niveau
du site si com
le plan d'opération interne ou en dehors
de ce site c'est le plan particulier
d'intervention
il a été déclenché dans les accidents
que vous soulevez cac 40 mais c'est
effectivement la réponse des pouvoirs
publics vis-à-vis de ce type d'accident
de cette possibilité qui n'est jamais
nul de voir se réaliser un accident on
parlera aussi de tous les contrôles
opérés sur ces sites ces incidents bien
sûr ont des conséquences
rappelons clos qui a été rejetée dans la
scène suite à l'incendié du siaap à
achères engendré la mort de trois tonnes
de poissons il ya une inquiétude
dix millions dix millions de poissons
dit a dit 'on merci merci pour cette
précision il ya une inquiétude une
inquiétude particulière des associations
environnementales sur sur cette question
de l'implantation des sites seveso dans
les yvelines
bien sûr il ya une inquiétude d'autant
plus que d'après ce que j'ai pu lire il
ya eu une augmentation des accidents et
en particulier pour moitié des incendies
1 47 % des accidents qui ont été
recensés des accidents industriels sont
des incendies effectivement le siaap
lubrizol sont la raffinerie ce sont des
incendies qui sont liées souvent à des
problèmes de maintenance se fait par des
organismes extérieurs
d'où l'inquiétude des organisations de
défense de l'environnement sur justement
les contrôler la présence de ces équipes
extérieures qui ne connaissent pas
toujours les sites je crois que c'est là
l'un des soucis des organisations et des
associations
sur ce sujet nous ralentir le l'occasion
parlons pardon de parler de ses
inquiétudes dans cette émission je vais
y arriver je vais juste donner la parole
à didier fischer maire de coignières de
sites seveso sur votre commune
un an seuil haut la raffinerie du midi
qui stocke et entre pro entrepose des
carburants est ce qu'il ya une
inquiétude de votre part quand vous
voyez ce qui s'est passé à achères quand
vous voyez ce qui s'est passé à rouen
où il ya eu notamment des personnes qui
ont été hospitalisées ensuite à suite à
cet incident non c'est évident qu'il ya
une inquiétude j'ai une inquiétude de la
population mais mais il n'y a pas de
psychose à poigne r on n'est pas dans un
état de psychose par rapport à ces
installations pétrolières mais c'est des
installations qui sont potentiellement
dangereuses et donc il faut prendre les
mesures de sécurité qui s'imposent et je
pense que moi d'ailleurs à la suite je
dirais de l'incident de rouen l'accident
de même de roi
j'ai pris la décision de
d'éclairer au préfet un courrier pour
lui demander quelle serait l'attitude à
tenir en cas d'un accident majeur un peu
comme comme à rouen donc il m'a renvoyé
au pprt op pays évidemment
et là vous avez pu visiter la leur
effectivement prison mediative
d'organiser une visite du site trapil et
rm donc raffinerie du midi avec mes
collègues notamment maire du mesnil
saint denis et de lévis un nom je
pensais qu'il était normal qu'un élu se
rendent sur le lieu
et là j'ai découvert d'ailleurs à cette
occasion que c'était la première fois
qu'ils voyaient des mers pénétrer dans
le site
donc c'est pas l'habitude apparemment
des élus d'aller se promener sur ces
sites dangereux
cela dit bon la visite nous a plutôt
rassuré on a vu concrètement les mesures
de sécurité il ya effectivement de
vraies mesures de sécurité qui sont
prises il ya des personnels qui sont
formés il y à des exercices qui sont
fait très régulièrement
enfin bon on est quand même rassuré
jusqu'à maintenant sur sur coignières
nous avons eu que des incidents mineurs
c'est pas on n'est pas sur des choses de
type
wow notamment dans votre bail à monsieur
le préfet vous parliez de huit incidents
recensés en 2006 d un cd un cd ainsi la
razer incident mineur pour l'instant
mais bon il faut faire attention un
incident mineur peut devenir incidents
plus graves par la suite donc il faut
faire attention mais bon je vois aller à
la raffinerie du midi comme tracts ils
ont quand même investi d'une manière
relativement importante ces dernières
années donc ça c'est quand même plutôt
rassurant pour le maire que je suis et
qui se préoccupe évidemment de la
sécurité de ses habitants et d'une
manière générale pour la population
quand même leur j'avais vu à quai c'est
henri qu'elle t'aime pas cher c'est
important que les maires soient rassurés
justement puisse visiter ses
installations alors d'une part il existe
un certain nombre de modes de
d'information des populations et bien
entendu le relais privilégié pour
l'information des populations et ça
reste le maire appuyé par les par les
ong par les associations et c'est bien
pour ça et d'ailleurs qu'au tour de
chacun de ces sites seveso
il est constitué une commission de suivi
de sites qui a justement pour mission
d'informer
héééé et en toute transparence air que
monsieur le maire a parlé d' huit
incidents
effectivement ça va d'incidents est
extrêmement bénins mais qu'il faut de
toute façon analysés pour les côtes
séquence potentiel qu'ils auraient pu
avoir un accident
ça démarre toujours par quelque chose
qui n'est pas forcément quelque chose de
majeur donc quel retour qu'elle regarde
on porte là dessus et en le faisant
d'une manière totalement ouverte et
transparente vis-à-vis notamment d'aider
la population alors avec des niveaux
peut-être différent parce que je suis
pas sûr que l'on construit toii 1 ont
tous les jours envie de savoir quelle
incidence est passé dans tel ou tel dans
telle ou telle entreprise mais d'avoir
effectivement ce retour vers les élus
verts les organisations non
gouvernementales de manière à bien
expliquer ce qui se passe
quelle est l'action de l'exploitant
parce que c'est lui le premier
responsable de sa sécurité et de l'état
derrière le travail de collaboration ça
c'est primordial pour les associations
sur votre association on a un rôle de
relais justement d'information et en cas
d'accident justement le problème c'est
d'avoir accès à l'information et là
parfois on se heurte effectivement à
quelques blocages mais on en reparle
juste après persévérant vous parlez de
réunions de suivi justement suite à
l'incendié du siaap il est plusieurs
réunions de suivi cinq mois après l
incendie
la secrétaire d'état auprès de la
ministre de la transition écologique et
solidaire emmanuelle wargon s'est rendu
sur place
elle a pu constater sur site les dégâts
et prendre connaissance des avancées et
des différents audits regardez ce
reportage de nicolas d'andré des débris
des escaliers des murs en ruines les
dégâts causés par l'incendié de la
station d'épuration d'achères le 3
juillet dernier
plus précisément sur l' usine c'est
naval de saint germain en laye du siaap
chargée de traiter les eaux usées
six mois plus tard les premiers éléments
émergent suite aux expertises sur les
causes de ce sinistre sur de purs cattin
maintenant son cul plus particulière et
visez donc quatre causes possibles
différentes tous d'origine électrique
donc on va patienter le temps que
l'espère du de l'assurance puisse aller
au bout de sa mission
actuellement une installation provisoire
fonctionne pour traiter les eaux usées
pour comprendre et tirer les
conséquences trois audits sont en cours
emmanuelle wargon secrétaire d'état
auprès de la ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire est venu
constater les dégâts et échanger avec
les parties prenantes
on a lancé de façon très sérieuse toutes
les procédures permettant d'aller au
bout des causes est au bout de
l'amélioration des mesures de précaution
et de prévention
après il manquait un plan de prévention
et d'information des habitants qui sera
validée d'ici quelques jours
probablement d'ici la fin de l'année
et du coup ça permettra d'engager une
discussion plus structurée avec les
riverains sur quoi faire qu'il faut
prévenir et mettre tout en oeuvre pour
que les mesures préventives de sécurité
empêche totalement je dirais une
catastrophe
c'est là-dessus véritablement qui vont
mettre le paquet pour éviter que l'on
passe au niveau pp c'est à dire c'est
trop tard une nouvelle réunion de suivi
doit avoir lieu fin janvier début
février avec les premiers résultats des
audits avec peut-être les raisons de cet
incendie sur ce site industriel lui se
calquer ma chère pour évacuer ce sujet
de comment étaient gérés 7,7 après crise
justement ça a été géré comme il ya eu
des réunions de suivi on l'a vu des
audits commandés aussi alors il ya eu
effectivement une réaction assez forte
des services de l'état dès le lendemain
un arrêté préfectoral en joignant un
certain nombre d'études notamment sur
les causes de ce sinistre et sur ses
conséquences
il faut rappeler c'est que les
conséquences de l'incendié du siat sont
essentiellement ce qu'on pourrait
qualifier de conséquence indirecte c'est
rc lamy soeur fonction de cette station
du fait de l'incendié qui a causé
l'essentiel des dommages à
l'environnement et qui continuent
d'ailleurs à reposer un certain nombre
est ensuite derrière effectivement un
arrêté en octobre qui a imposé un
certain nombre d'audits de sécurité dont
un dont nous attendons très rapidement
pour février les résultats qui portent
sur la défense et la lutte contre l'
incendie
je rejoins madame jaouen
en constatant une augmentation de ces
incendies et surtout une augmentation
des conséquences de ces incendies
et c'est un point sur lequel nous nous
employons effectivement à travailler
dommage qu'il faut qu'il y ait un
accident un incident important pour que
des mesures soient prises
ça c'est quand même pas rassurant tout
ça on alors aujourd'hui on a entendu
emmanuel verny parler de la mise en
place d'un voile en d'information de
sensibilisation politique cet effort en
place ça alors il sait c'est quand même
un peu étonnant on est quand même sur
des sur des sites sensibles
sur terminer on laisserait pas internet
sur des sites sensibles
bon moi j'ai été rassuré attrape il est
au raffinerie du midi
et là j'ai eu des choses la lutte contre
l'incendié notamment
bon bon ça m'a l'air ça m'a l'air assez
sécurisés ils ont fait des
investissements pour mieux sécuriser les
choses depuis quelques années donc ça
m'a l'air assez sécurisé de ce côté là
mais il ya peut-être des sites
effectivement qu'ils le sont moins dans
les villes que vous regretterez toute
cette réflexion là bas après moi par
exemple moi aussi par exemple j'ai
découvert ma commune n'avait pas pcs
plan communal de sauvegarde ça c'est de
la responsabilité des élus mois les les
maires précédents n'avaient pas
finaliser le document alors qu'ils y
travaillait depuis 2000 13 ans mais n'en
est qu'a fait monsieur donc ça c'est
quand même assez c'est quand même assez
assez surprenant donc aujourd'hui moi je
suis en train de finaliser ce plan pour
que la commune se dote d'un vrai plan de
communal de sauvegarde
et ça ça permet quand même je dirais de
prendre les devants au moment d'une
église majeur alors plan communal de
sauvegarde s'est pas seulement les
pétroliers ça peut être un accident sur
la la nationale 10 à peut-être du
verglas
voilà de la neige et du verglas qui
bloque tout le monde et on est obligé de
comment dire de de faire en sorte
d'abriter d'héberger des personnes de
passage on ouvre le gymnase on ouvre la
maison comment les salons marcel de
saint-exupéry exupéry voilà voilà des
exemples là je vais vous laisser bon
l'effet de masse sur les mesures là je
vais vous donner d'abord marie josé
rossi jeunes comme ça ça vous permettra
de répondre vous vous disiez tout à
l'heure les ce que les associations
telles étaient associés dans ce
processus est ce qu'il ya eu
l'information communiquée en tout cas
sur sur cet incident étaient conviés aux
réunions effectivement sur le siaap
d'achères donc on a pu suivre les
informations données par le siaap et des
dispositions prises effectivement par
l'état ceci dit en lisant le contenu du
dernier arrêté préfectoral donc imposant
des audits de sécurité constate quand
même que les questions de sécurité
d'information de formation de
maintenance de prévention des accidents
et en particulier tout ce qui concerne
la sécurité incendie sont clairement
mentionné et j'ai lu aussi des rapports
de comités de
suivi de sites et il ya beaucoup de
comment s'appelle le monsieur kalt et de
la chine ne démentira pas je pense il ya
beaucoup de remarques qui sont qui sont
indiqués sur justement des défaillances
quant au processus de sécurité aux
alarmes au système fonctionnel enfin il
ya quand même des défaillances qui sont
notés sur la plupart des sites en
matière de de formation du personnel de
notion de risque et d'eux mêmes de
systèmes moyen d'intervention on va vous
laisser répondre en récoltait de bascher
même si c'est parfois minimes la durée
on était calaisis d'une part il est
normal et c'est tout à fait normal que
nos concitoyens par la voix des élus et
des ong nous rappelle à nos devoirs mais
ça ça fait partie des choses qui sont
qui sont tout à fait normal ceci étant
comme dans beaucoup de choses l'arbre
cache un peu la forêt est souvent ce
type d'accident
permet de mettre en lumière ce que l'on
pensait être des dysfonctionnements et
skins est globalement que la conséquence
d'un certain nombre d'actes qui ont été
pris bien au préalable la totalité de
ces sites ont été autorisés ils ont fait
d'ailleurs l'objet lors de cette
autorisation d'une étude des dangers
d'une enquête publique
c'est pas des choses qu'on fait le soir
la veillée à la préfecture c'est
vraiment des choses qui sont faites dans
la plus grande transparence c'est aussi
masqué en disant ça le fait de demander
à l'exploitant de se reposer un certain
nombre de questions
ces masques et aussi le travail des
services de l'état d' analyse de ce qui
a été fait je voudrais quand même citer
quelques chiffres la drieu dans les
yvelines c'est plus de 200 visites
d'inspection aujourd'hui sur 2018 c'est
44 mise en demeure
c'est très astreintes administratives et
donc c'est un travail du quotidien qui
est fait par aller 10 personnes sur
l'ensemble des 280 sites soumis à
autorisation et 2006 soumis à
déclaration
donc il ya un travail de fond qui est
fait avec les moyens qui lui sont
alloués
il y à une véritable analyse on utilise
aussi beaucoup nos collègues du niveau
régional qui ont une technique une
technicité particulière sur ce type de
sur ce type de site mais que nous
aurait-on dit a contrario si on avait
dit bah oui il ya eu le feu eh bien eh
bien on va les autoriser à redémarrer
non il faut bien qu effectivement l'état
impose
mais ce n'est pas un audit abine is you
c'est bien le fait de revenir et de se
dire il ya eu des choses qui ont
peut-être dysfonctionné en l'occurrence
sur le site d'achères il s'avère ça a
été révélé lors d'une des réunions
d'information que l'un des bâtiments
l'une des unités de ce site n'était même
pas équipés de détection de d'équipement
de détecteurs de fumée dans son nid
voisin
vous me permettrez de ne pas rentrer
dans un cas particulier qui fait l'objet
à la fois d'une enquête judiciaire et
d'une enquête interne aux associations
de savoir si ces questions rigaux oui
mais ça c'est aussi alors il habitait
exploitant sait pas alors il ya deux
questions là dedans il ya le contrôle et
jeudi et comme je vous l'aï dit on est
quand même à 44 mise en demeure c'est à
dire une part traitement une sur cinq
qui donne lieu à une mise en demeure
donc ce contrôle et rigoureux après
encore faut-il que l'état du fait des
lois et règlements soit en situation
d'imposer un certain nombre de choses
moi je ne peux pas et nous sommes
heureusement d'ailleurs dans un état de
droit qui fait que je ne peux pas par
exemple arriver dans une entreprise et
dire je vous impose de la détection
incendie
si ce n'est prévu par un certain nombre
de textes et règlements
donc moi je constate et je fais un
contrôle rigoureux mais de même qu'un
agent sur le bord de la route vous
contrôlera il vérifiera si votre vitesse
dépasse la vitesse limite autorisée ou
pas mais c'est pas pour ça que vous
allez diminuer ou augmenter la vitesse
sur cette portion de route
alors pour ceux qui nous suivent depuis
le début de ce débat ce qui nous
rejoignent peut-être vous entendez
souvent le mot seveso il faut juste
rappeler d'où vient ce terme seveso
seveso c'est le nom d'une ville du nord
de l'italie en lombardie en 1974 un
nuage herbicides s'échappe d'une usine
chimique causant une catastrophe
industrielle et sanitaires 193 personnes
hospitalisées le nuage a tué trois mille
animaux domestiques 77 mille têtes de
bétail ont dû être abattus l'union
européenne alors décidé de mettre en
place une politique commune pour
prévenir un ces risques industriels
majeurs et ils ont mis donc en place
cette directive seveso
nous sommes actuellement je le précise
sous la norme seveso 3 la directive
seveso 3 qui est entrée en vigueur en
2015 environ dix mille sites sont
concernés en europe et donc 13 dans les
yvelines juste sur l'implantation
géographique au mans on décide de
l'implantation géographique vous en
parliez tout à l'heure le rappel
historique que vous avez fait est tout à
fait fondée ce qu'il faut la première
directive c'est 80 de ses 82 c'est ça
qu'il faut pas perdre de vue c'est que
la législation sur les établissements
dangereux incommode et insalubres elle
remonte à napoléon c'est un décret-loi
de 18 cents vi qui a fondé la politique
en matière de prévention des risques un
en france alors effectivement là dessus
est venue se rajouter un niveau européen
avec une remise à niveau qui d'ailleurs
pour un certain nombre d'items
correspondait déjà à ce qu'ils étaient
ce qui a été fait en france le gros je
dirais apports de la directive seveso et
notamment de la directive seveso 2 c'est
l'arrivée des plans de prévention des
risques technologiques plan de
prévention des risques technologiques
qui sont issus de la catastrophe de
toulouse et qui ont permis de maîtriser
l'urbanisme autour de ces sites la
plupart des sites dont nous parlons sont
des sites qui sont anciens qui sont qui
ont été implantés avant même l'arrivée
de cette directive et la directive
d'ailleurs à cette particularité qu'elle
n'intervient pas sur la création
d'installations seveso mais bien sûr
leur fonctionnement
cirque est ce qu'il doit comment
dirais-je accompagner leur
fonctionnement en matière de plan de
prévention et en protection civile de
mesures de maîtrise des risques pour
diminuer le risque à la source mais en
aucun cas d'ailleurs la directive ne se
positionnent sur le fait d'implanter ou
non une installations seveso
alors je veux qu'il nous reste trois
minutes on va faire un tour de table
marie josé rossi jaouen votre sentiment
sur ces contrôles est ce qu'à votre avis
ils sont assez rigoureux est ce que il
ya assez de contrôle
quelle est votre recette moment fnl
déplore que
il ya une baisse actuellement des moyens
donnés aux ministères de la transition
écologique des suppressions de postes
sont prévues
donc nous nous inquiétons du suivi
justement de ces contrôles dont on
espère qu'ils vont être maintenus et
c'est sur ce point en particulier que
nous serons vigilants
d'autre part nous fêtons aussi qu'il y
ait plus de participation des
associations dans les comités de suivi
et des réunions d'informations de façon
à ce que les administrés la population
puisse avoir une vision la plus juste et
éviter 10 ont une trop grande anxiété
vis-à-vis de ses sites industriels suite
à ces accidents récents didier fischer
en tant que maire vous êtes au contact
géographique direct puisque voilà qu'est
ce que vous pensez qu est-ce que ces
contrôles vont rigoler ce qu'on peut les
améliorer ou contre mon contact
géographique direct oui bien sûr mais ma
la question que je me pose c'est est ce
que vraiment est ce que l'état vraiment
les moyens finalement 2
de tout cela est ce que comme le disait
madame aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il ya
des coupes budgétaires il ya des baisses
de moyens donc c'est quand même un petit
peu inquiétant au moment où justement où
il ya recrudescence d'incidents ou
d'accidents
donc je pense que là
l'état aurait aujourd'hui et les tailles
surtout ceux qui votent les lois et ceux
qui votent les budgets aurait intérêt
quand même à se pencher sérieusement sur
la question
justement afin de pouvoir par ces moyens
assurer véritablement la sécurité de ces
lieux quoi le mot de l'avenant si si
henri bacher est-ce qu'on peut les
améliorer ce qu'il ya une amélioration
possible
c'est sur cette thématique les jeunes
troll je ne peux protection je ne peux
décemment refuser les moyens
supplémentaires mais ça c'est dit c'est
que finalement nous sommes nous sommes
dit ça correspond à une dotation moyenne
voient la méthode de calcul qui permet
d'arriver à ce type à ce type de
chiffres pour la première année en 2020
nous ne subirons pas de diminution des
effectifs dans les règles et contrôles
c'est c'est une bonne nouvelle ça veut
dire également qu'il faut que nous
adoptions une politique de contrôle un
peu plus ciblés et qu'on analyse là
aussi les incidents et accidents pour
concentrer nos moyens de contrôle sur à
la limite les installations qui le
méritent
entre kim et le plus c'est ce qu'a fait
la dri yeux donc notamment vous verrez
apparaître bientôt sur le site de la
tribune un certain nombre de sites dits
en surveillance renforcée
dans l'ensemble de l'île de france c'est
ici sur lesquels effectivement nous
allons apporter une pression de contrôle
un peu plus importante qu'on le faisait
au préalable et bien manière sûre je ne
veux pas
merci en tout cas pour votre éclairage
merci à votre participation à tous les
trois voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission 7,8 débat rendez-vous le mois
prochain pour une nouvelle émission
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]